this is one of the most impressive
dynasties that you probably didn't know
about Oklahoma softball just won their
third straight title and sixth
championship in 10 years only one other
D1 softball program has ever done that
and it was UCLA from 1988 to 1990.
yesterday's win also extended Oklahoma's
win streak to 53 games and the woman
leading the team is not messing around
clearly head coach Patty gosso is the
highest paid coach in Division One
softball and she built the program from
the ground up 30 years ago the team was
playing in a park that was also shared
by a softball beer league team and now
they're moving to a brand new crazy nice
Stadium on campus next year